good morning Mr Hearn
good morning Trevor
Now American presidential visits to
Ireland now seem to take on the flavor
almost of pilgrimages
um what do you think this one actually
achieved
well I think the president United States
of America or of that matters most heads
of state are always very welcome in in
Ireland
um I think President Biden for you know
50 years has been a very good friend of
Ireland in all his roles down through
the years he's been here many times he's
been here twice as vice president and
um I I think you know that he addressed
the doll building up that relationship
with the parliamentarians of today you
know moving around the country as he did
from Northern Ireland to the Border
counties where his relatives come from
to the west of Ireland and and meeting
fairly well you know huge amounts of
people from various organizations you
know that strengthens our you know
contact with the United States which is
hugely important also as you know and
the enormous amount of American firms
that are in Ireland a huge amount of
investment that we receive from from
America and the amount of Irish
companies that are now operating in
America very successfully
well as you know um President Biden's
affections for Ireland
um playing as it is hasn't uh all
entirely been uh taken in a positive way
here he said that the UK should work
more closely with Ireland support the
people of Northern Ireland what do you
suppose he meant by that remark
well I suppose he he was referring back
to the fact that uh prior to Rishi sunak
there was very little contact between
the Irish government and the British
government and the
institutions of the godfreight agreement
and the predictably the British Irish
Council
um hadn't met for a long period
success of prime ministers hadn't
attended I think the last one did
attended before Rishi sunak's attention
attendance in November was Gordon Brown
and you know it was your last interview
who's got that that must have been back
13 14 years ago so I'm sure he was
referring to that because it was a bit
hard quite frankly that countries that
are so close together
um couldn't get a British prime minister
to attend a British Irish
intergovernmental Council for that
length of time
but I I think you of all people uh will
will understand the sensitivities here
the former first minister of Northern
Ireland Arlene Foster says that Joe
Biden I'm quoting here hates the United
Kingdom
um do you think that there's some part
of him that is basically anti-british
no I don't I don't um isn't he working
very closely with the British government
and Ukraine isn't there non-stop
contacts with between the British
government and the United States and you
know we have to live in the Years where
we found it very difficult Trevor to get
involvement from the United States that
didn't go through the British government
and there was a time that we were told
when I was younger that Northern Ireland
was none of our business that was
totally
um a UK matter now thankfully we've all
matured and got a bit of sense and cop
on and moved on from those days
um so you know nowadays thankfully there
is dialogue and we've built up
relationships but you know I I think it
is good for President Biden to remind
people that that's the way it should be
um uh Mr and I I know that you're um uh
a legendary Diplomat in many ways but
I'm sensing that behind this is a sigh
of relief that Boris Johnson is no
longer in number 10 Downing Street
no to be honest it it doesn't really
matter a driver to me who the prime
minister of United Kingdom is that's the
matter for the United Kingdom but yet
you'll appreciate and that we found it
very difficult to deal with piracy he
seems to be a very colorful guy and a
very nice guy but you know we had the
trouble with the backstop with the
trouble with the protocol we had a lot
of trouble with brexit in the first
place quite frankly I don't think we
would have had the institutions in order
and Ireland down
um on and off for the last six or seven
years if it hadn't been for brexit in
this course of some told difficulties
and problems but you know we we try in
Ireland to live in the future which we
try and get on with things and you know
I think what we now need to do issue
soon actress prime minister he has
really done a good job in in our
estimation here within the last six
months he has invigorated the efforts to
get everything working in Northern
Ireland a huge amount of positives to
come out of the Good Friday agreement
it's not just in terms of of the you
know the peace but an enormous amount of
the the various part of the agreement
the legislation the demilitarization you
know dealing with the prisoners you know
dealing with so many of the north south
issues have have gone away and we now
are left with the political one with the
institutions and
um In fairness the Prime Minister issue
soon he's really trying to to resolve
that matter the Windsor framework I
think nearly solves all those issues
there seems to be a few outstanding ones
that we have to be resolved in I hope to
meet you at the Prime Minister on
Wednesday because this week in Northern
Ireland all of the people who were
involved 25 years ago including Tony
Blair and President Clinton and Hillary
Clinton and all will be in Northern
Ireland for the next three days so
hopefully we'll have a chance of of you
know being able to communicate with each
other
well as one
as architects of that agreement and you
as you say you'll be meeting with uh the
other people who made this happen will
there be a tinge of disappointment uh in
that group you Clinton so on that a
quarter of a century on
the devolved government is still in
advance
yeah that is a disappointment Trevor it
it's um you know we we set up the system
based on on power sharing uh where
everything has to be agreed on the
cross-community basis now the the
problem for us that that's that's been
difficult
um and if one side are unhappy with
something they can pull out now that's
what we at the top of your piece there
you said where I said there should be a
review I I think you can't have a
situation in a democracy you know that
every time somebody is unhappy with
something that they can just pull down
the institutions you can imagine if that
was to happen in Westminster or happen
in dollar and
um so we have to try and find a way of
dealing with that and you know if we've
brought it down in different things over
the years and the last time when
champagne were involved they came down
over cash for ash which was an
environmental uh Grant system at this
time it came down effectively over
initiative to do with brexit but we have
to try and find a way that it only comes
down when there's elections and we have
to find a resolution of that but it has
to be done in across Community basis
Northern Ireland is still a divided
Society we've made a lot of progress but
there there still are our problems of of
integration and
um so when we we make any fundamental
changes if it's not across Community
consensus in my view anyway everyone
doesn't agree with me that it has to be
done by agreement and it's the only way
we'll make progress but that is the
disappointment I think I'm happy with so
many so many things we did 25 years ago
but the institutions not been up and
running is very unsatisfactory
well you know one of the I guess your
triumphs was that um you had to deal
with what I suppose many people would
say is one of the most difficult
Personalities in Irish politics indeed
politics anywhere the Reverend Ian
Paisley and you got it across the line
um bearing in mind that experience what
would you be saying to his successes in
the dop now when they say we're just not
going back into the institutions until
we get our way on for example the
protocol
well your politics is the art of
compromise and I dealt with the late
David Trimble for a long time and as
you've said the lady in Paisley and all
the time we were able to make the
progress because we were prepared to to
compromise
um
then you've had you know first Minister
Mr Robinson come in and with uh Martin
McGinnis and you know I I think we Peter
Robinson Mark McGinnis I think Randy
institutions very very well and it was
on the base as a compromise was on the
basis of of trying to see where they
could get a middle ground and you know
you you do not make much progress in
politics if you don't do that and I
think we have to get away from you know
that this is the position and no other
position is satisfactory I mean it's not
tenable they're sustainable and it's not
in the interest of the people in
Northern Ireland there are huge issues
in Northern Ireland as there is
everywhere else including here in Dublin
but you know the only way because I I
can't let you go away without asking a
question which I respect our viewers in
Ireland would like to know the answer to
there have been a lot of presidents
wondering about the British Isles in the
last couple of weeks and more to come
with Clinton's on
um now the Irish President Michael D
Higgins will step down in 2025 I I note
that you've recently rejoined uh your
Fiona foil party
um are you going to be the Party's
candidate for president next time around
um I remember the councilor State Trevor
and I I work I'm advised the president
whenever he seeks Our advice
um he's two and a half years to run and
a big support of the president and
traditionally in our protocols we don't
get into that issue until about five or
six months before the election so so the
answer to that is all in the future
I'm not hearing a no
thank you very much Mr aherne
thank you for Trevor and good morning to
you